we're gonna be proving a whole bunch of
things right and to be most specific
you're gonna write a whole bunch of
equations like you know angles that
relate to each other all lines write the
equations that you write should match
the reasons that support them the
equations that you write should match
the reasons that support them okay so my
classic example for this is he's am he's
a triangle okay he is an angle and if I
call that seven degrees and that 44
let's can put the off scale but you go
get it okay so fine theta theta what
would be your reasoning for how you what
will be the actual property of a
triangle that you use in order to find
what theatre is it is the angles of a
triangle is 180 degrees okay
the I'm gonna write this because so it's
to illustrate this is quite important
right the angle sum all they triangle
degree so that's my reason okay that's
my reason my equation that sort of
proceed insists should he exactly match
what this is talking about okay so for
example let me give you an instance of
let's see if this away of a sentence and
equation that's true but does it match
this right theta equals
this equation is true absolutely true
you will give me fever okay it just
doesn't match yes why not
because there is this sum here there's
no Sun this is a difference in fact a
couple of differences yeah
so yes this will get me the right answer
but the line that should have preceded
this that should be attached to this
reason is theta plus 37 plus 44 equals
180 okay this matches this in fact it's
the symbolic version on what this is
verbally right they should match up okay
now you're gonna you're gonna lose a
mark for saying this rather is probably
not probably not but I'm not just in
this like we're not I just established
we're not in this just about like
getting you to memorize some rules so
you can reproduce something create
correctly I'm trying to get you to
understand mathematics right and how
logic works this is the way logic works
this is the way logic should be okay so
constructing is like that this is a
trivially simple example because it's
easy for me to illustrate later on it
gets a bit more sophisticated right and
when you construct this reason when you
think it when you identify what reason
you want you need to construct this
equation so it carefully matches so that
it is clear what you are proving and how
does that make sense
now just while I'm on this I'll make a
quick note which sort of shoehorns into
point too much lots of people asking
about angle some triangle um I would
highly recommend against writing this
okay now let me finish right the reason
why is because what does this mean and
you're like clearly it's a triangle
right like look at my context in that
kind of thing sure okay
fine but it just so happens especially
in the mathematics that we've been
learning recently that this thing means
at least two different themes that are
completely different at least to give me
one okay at first it means change right
it's Delta right and then the other one
which we kind of gonna lead into enough
I mentioned before is that it's equal to
this what's this guy actually just
screaming
right so they use Delta D for
discriminant okay and these are
completely different yeah it's like oh
what are you doing now you can use you
can use triangles triangle shapes to
indicate triangles here's where you can
use them if you're trying those named
and almost certainly at our level of
mathematics the train will usually be
named okay you know if it's not named
just name the thing okay um this is
faster this is faster than right then a
triangle like if you want to really be
neatly be okay and I think this is clear
up to clear up right like in a given
question you might have like four or
five or six triangles which one are you
talking about it's all about trying to
present something which is as convincing
as possible because you're going to
prove something if you had a good
diagram right and it is there with your
proof your diagram constitutes a part of
your proof okay so if I've done this if
I've done this and this is on my page
then this is the totally legit in fact
you might even see I'll pull some out
for you when it's time questions in the
exam will often say pot one Joule one
mark draw the diagram in your in your
blah blah blah and then part two
actually do something with that diagram
guess what we are not actually trying to
assess your ability to draw a diagram
when I try to make things easier for you
to construct your proof and for us to
market and know why on earth you're
talking about so you can put some labels
on here and construct them whatever
yes yes is the short answer
now like I said if it's a deducted
geometry proof it would be pretty sloppy
in the exam anyway if you got given
something and there were no labels on it
you may have to put some extra labels on
and you would do that on your diagram
and you would make it clear and that
would be fine okay any other questions J
and that's my mom okay it's at exactly
the same I would say it's worth saying
angle doesn't come up as frequently in a
reason but sometimes it does I would
probably not write that right because
like like a triangle on its own it
doesn't mean so many other things but it
just looks honestly it looks like an L I
could sit into it right there so I would
probably say this is fine because that's
pretty clear clear what you are saying
whereas this is not so much if you like
this would you loser mind
probably not but that doesn't make it
clear right like we are not in this game
just to try and minimize the amount of
work to get the maximum number of marks
we're trying to be good mathematicians
you mean like this
I would say one more thing which is
about that that whole transition where
you're trying to like oh I'm like more
often but not the reason why this is an
issue is because I am in an assessment
task that is limited time if I had a
million hours I'd write out everything
no problems okay so I get that you're
rushed right so here's his might like my
general principle so if you've got a
question and you know there's there's
three parts to it okay and you're like
I've got I've got plenty other questions
to go for and I look at Part A and I'm
like this is gonna require a
time-consuming proof okay the time
continuum proof and I know probably I'm
gonna run out of time if I spend all my
time here I need like thinking time as
well right what I will do is I will put
down some really really abbreviated
proof like I'll use stuff that I
wouldn't usually like like this right
and just get it on the page so I can
move on right now if I have time
afterwards to come back to this and
right angle instead of like a little
thing then I will or if I have time to
film in like some of the missing lines
which I was thinking but I just wanted
to get down the answer quicker so I
could move on then I will but if not
then if I didn't have that time it
probably was better spent on some other
question where three marks right so that
comes down to an exam technique to me
I'm in fact even further on when we get
not right now but like if you get into
extension 2 and we're looking at like
you know you've got a circle and there
are triangles in it so maybe at some
point you want to talk about the
similarity between two triangles which
are in there and they are similar okay
you know what they're gonna say they're
gonna do this they're gonna say triangle
ABC is PQR and they're gonna say this
phrase and you're like what on earth
does that mean and that means I can see
I can see it I can see it
I haven't proved it but now I'm gonna
use the fact that I've seen it and I can
build some other sound clear
mathematical things for which this is
not the point it's extension to
similarity was years ago this is not
what we're assessing right but it does
constitute a part of your proof yet to
say it right now you if you have some
time if you have some time you'll come
back and you'll actually feel in why
it's sim